believe it or not your next iPhone could
be fully waterproof and yes that
includes salt water and if you think I'm
absolutely crazy and nuts I'm gonna
prove it to you in this video and it all
starts with this patent right here Apple
refines their invention that will one
day allow snorkelers and divers to take
photos and videos with iPhone and
underwater mode and yes that implies
salt water because Hugo snorkeling and
fresh water nobody yes it's salt water
that means the ocean now if you look at
this image right here you can see
somebody recording with their iPhone
with a couple of simple buttons and they
have underwater mode turned on with
their depth being 2.7 meters under the
water here in Apple's patent it says
that an electronic device could be
configured to determine when it is
currently exposed to a moisture event in
some examples it could range from a
small amount of liquid liquid all the
way to being completely submerged within
a liquid with a couple of images here
showing a dry mode above land a wet mode
where it's wet but not fully submerged
and then an actual underwater mode now
if that sounds familiar to you it should
because Apple recently revealed their
Apple watch Ultra which actually has an
underwater mode where it's meant for
divers going deep underwater as you can
see and Apple's own promotional video
and as you can see people actually
tested it out right here on YouTube
showing that as soon as you go
underwater the underwater mode turns on
and they are using it showing it with
all the dev data and everything else and
it's awesome because the way that Apple
makes it work is that as soon as you
submerge your Apple watch Ultra the
depth app begins your dive and right
here in this iPhone patent it says that
an iPhone could determine that it's
exposed to a moisture event in example
submerged under water now if you didn't
already know the Apple watch Ultra has a
new depth gauge which provides real-time
measurement of underwater depth down to
40 meters along with water temperature
readings and I believe that that is
going to be coming to the iPhone very
soon and I also fully believe that this
waterproof iPhone is going to come with
the same en
13319 certification that the Apple watch
Ultra already has and that is going to
be very important and if you think about
it the Apple watch Ultra already has a
hundred meters of water resistance which
comes out to
328 feet now I don't know if the future
iPhone is going to be coming with that
level of water proofing but it would be
absolutely insane if it happens so now
let me give you the evidence for why I
believe that the waterproof iPhone is
gonna be coming but before I get into
the actual evidence of how apple is
going to expand their iPhone's
waterproofing let me first show you how
you can expand your living room
experience with our partner like me's
new fantasy plus kit which extends the
colors in action Beyond just the screen
this works great for music and movies
since it supports doubly vision and HDR
10 plus as well as for gaming with
support for 4K 60 where many similar
price competitors can only do 1080p the
full kit price is incredible at 299
dollars whereas a matching Hue sync kit
that supports the same formats comes in
at over 900 dollars it's also incredibly
easy to set up you just peel and stick
the light strip around your TV and then
download the app to sync it up they have
multiple modes and options so you can
use the app and customize however you
like best and it's voice compatible with
Amazon Alexa Google assistant and and
smart things and even better light me is
giving the biggest discount of the Year
20 off on all lightning products for
Black Friday and Cyber Monday so check
the link in the description below to
stay tuned now getting back to the
evidence of the waterproof iPhone the
first piece of the puzzle the first step
that Apple has already made with their
new iPhone 14 series is of course
removing the SIM card tray on all iPhone
14 models in the US I believe that is
the first step because having that
physical SIM card tray allows water to
seed in especially salt water and now
the next step actually was revealed by
the leaker Ming Chi quo with his latest
survey indicating that the volume button
and power button of the two high-end
iPhone 15 models will be adapting solid
state button designs which is similar to
the old home button where it switch from
a physical mechanical design to a solid
state where it's actually not moving
there's no crack nothing there's just a
taptic engine basically behind it that
feels like a click just like this track
pad on this MacBook Pro so instead of
having just one main taptic engine there
will be three taptic engines a new one
for the volume buttons and a new one for
the power button and that's going to be
the second step towards going with a new
waterproof iPhone design because there
will no longer be cracks there's no way
for water to seep into there so
basically now next year we're gonna have
iPhones with no physical SIM card tray
and no physical buttons at all the only
thing left is going to be the port
because as mixture quo also recently
said just a couple of days ago all of
next year's iPhones will ditch the
lightning port and switch over to USB
type-c whether that's going to be
Thunderbolt or regular lightning 2.0 it
doesn't matter the fact is we are still
gonna have a USBC Port next year which
causes an issue for the waterproof
iPhone situation now what Apple's been
doing for the last few years is updating
their iPhones in a certain tick tock
tick cycle where one year you'll get a
full redesign the next year you'll get
some big feature changes maybe some
battery life or something else and then
the third year for example they could
focus on a huge camera update and now
next year we are expecting another full
redesign for the iPhone 15 lineup
including the 15 Pro which will include
a new design potentially with a slab of
Glass on the front and the back and USB
type c like Ming Chico was saying now
here is where it gets interesting Mark
German the most reliable Apple leaker
says that Apple's move to USBC is just a
stop Gap until its Wireless future now
if you don't know what he's talking
about check this out within his
Bloomberg article here's what he said he
said at some point in the next few years
Apple will probably begin transitioning
entirely to inductive charging on the
iPhone 8 iPad matching the Apple watch
the EU says that smart watches are
exempt from its new law as are devices
that don't charge over a wired
connection so I'd bet Mark German would
bet that inductive charging and Apple's
Wireless future is an effective work
around so essentially Apple can get
around those EU laws by going fully
Wireless which means no ports no ports
at all a portless iPhone and guess what
happened back in 2019 Ming Chico
reported that Apple was working on a
completely wireless iPhone completely
portless but of course that that got
delayed but I think it is coming with
the next redesign cycle yes my personal
prediction that I've already posted to
Twitter is that the
2026 portless iPhone will be the first
smartphone ever that will be fully
waterproof even salt water how no ports
yes because there's no SIM card tray no
physical buttons and no Port which means
it's going to be essentially fully
sealed just like the Apple watch because
if you think about it the Apple watch
has a speaker the Apple watch has a
microphone and that's essentially all
that will be exposed on the iPhone if
they get rid of that final Port so with
that said it's gonna be pretty easy for
Apple at that point to make the iPhone
finally waterproof including salt water
just like the Apple watch Ultra that can
go down 40 meters diving depth in salt
water which is absolutely insane and I
think that this patent that I showed you
guys points to that happening and I
think it's happening in 2026 now you
might be asking well how the heck are we
supposed to transfer our data using a
wired cable for backups or whatever else
well there is this extra patent that
I've shown you guys many months ago a
couple of times on our videos but you
may have forgotten check this out this
patent is dated March 30th
2017 and guess what it shows Apple
events a wireless charging system that
puts equal emphasis on wireless data
transfers and guess what that wireless
charging system is well if you look
closely you have magnets for alignment
you have an inductive ring it's
basically Max safe yes the wireless
charging Max save Puck that we already
have is pointing to this patent look you
can see right here a cable a day data
Puck yes that's Max save but if you look
closely at this patent you can see
second Optical data transfer module
first Optical data transfer module
essentially on the inside of the iPhone
you can see right here this is the
iPhone in blue this is the back of the
iPhone there is a glass window and
inside of the Mac safe Puck there's
essentially a new data transfer module
that uses Optical light to transfer the
data and yes that light is probably
going to be ultra violet which means
that it can go through paint so you're
not even going to see a window there
it's going to go through paint and it's
going to transfer the data and all apple
is going to have to do is make a second
version of that wireless charging Max
safe puck now supporting data transfer
and that's how easy it's going to be for
Apple to go fully Wireless and fully
portless now if that blue you your mind
go ahead and hit the like button comment
down below that's the reason why I think
a fully waterproof iPhone is going to be
coming in 2026 so hopefully you enjoyed
that video and if you did click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]